this is not
an everyday arrest on our streets
instead
it's police manhandling and detaining a
father
right beside his dying daughter in
hospital
zenith was born with a rare genetic
illness which the family didn't know
about
until she was three in july last year
the six-year-old's health
rapidly deteriorated she was admitted to
hospital
struggling to breathe and put on life
support
but her parents both doctors say the
staff at the hospital in the north of
england
weren't giving her the correct treatment
they never listened to
to us they would never provide you know
explanations for their actions
because with my medical background
i'm an adult chest consultant and the
disease then
was suffering is is not uncommon
in adult population so i was able to
ask you know leading questions
in august 2019 the medics looking after
critically ill xenib
decided it was time to end her treatment
and she should be allowed to die
her parents insisted this wasn't the
right thing to do
leading to a bitter breakdown in the
relationship with the doctors treating
her
i believe that because our relationship
had deteriorated over the past 18 months
they had finally come to a decision that
this was it and they had made a decision
dr abbasi clung to his daughter's
bedside
refusing to leave denying the doctors
from removing the ventilator
which was keeping xenoblade
unfortunately we need to speak to you
outside
just been told about half an hour ago
that they are going to take the tube out
and our daughter is going to die
it meant police were called and what
unfolded
was far from civil i've got chest pain i
will take it in even
i've got medicine in my pocket i want to
have some
i've got medicine in my pocket if you
sit up reasonably on the chair we'll get
your medication
i can't i'm feeling dizzy dr abbasi
suffered from a heart attack
and was taken to a e i actually thought
that he was gonna die
and at one point i said to the nurses i
said am i gonna be
organizing two funerals they've told us
in a statement they've said we responded
to a call
of a man being violent and abusive
towards staff
and that he had assaulted a consultant
was that right
so if that was right why didn't they
come and arrest me
but then when they asked you to leave
the bed and go outside
why did you not comply to that because i
knew that
if i left the bed space i would not be
allowed to come back
we're human beings we're parents we're
told our daughter's going to die
and we're shouted at we were treated we
were treated like scum
the force also said while we recognize
this was a very distressing time
for him and his family our duty was to
ensure
the safety of all those present we have
reviewed the body-worn footage
from the incident which sets out a very
different picture to the limited version
of events
which have been presented to us the nhs
trust
which treated zineb offered their
heartfelt sympathies
and condolences to the family and they
told us their first priority
was to always act in the best interest
of their patients
in a statement they said on very rare
occasions
when there is a risk to the safety of
our staff or obstruction
and interference with the delivery of
care and treatment
it is necessary for us to seek help from
the police
following the incident the nhs trust
applied to the high court
for permission to take zenib off the
ventilator but in mid-september
just three days before the hearing was
due to start she died
i want the world to see so that it is
not allowed to happen anymore
the family are now taking legal action
against the police and the hospital
they're being supported by christian
concern a religious organization
but whoever is right or wrong in this
bitter feud
the footage of police dragging
distraught parents away from their dying
child
is an image many will struggle to forget
insaam rasheed sky news